[Animated graphic of a man shown from the waist up]
[Camera zooms in and fluoroscopic image of lungs is shown.]
[Apex, hilus, and base are indicated.]
[Fluoroscopic image of lungs as person breathes in and out. Lungs expand and contract.]
[Fluoroscopic image of lungs rotates around the chest]
[Aortic arch, tracheal bifurcation, and carina are indicated. ]
[Fluoroscopic images of lungs again appearing to rotate around the chest area]
[Fluoroscopic images of lungs containing a tumor. The beating heart is seen.]
[Carcinoma]
[Fluoroscopic images of lungs from different angles and sides of the chest; a mass is seen in upper right.]
[Carcinoma with abscess formation]
[Abscess is highlighted on left.]
[Horizontal level of fluid in the abscess is indicated]
[Images of the lungs with beating heart and dark spots indicating tumor and abscess]
[The person in the image rocks side to side; neck and shoulders are seen.]
[Animated image of lungs sprinkled with small growths is shown. ]
[Fluoroscopic images of lungs with tumors throughout.]
[Metastases of seminoma]
[Graphic of lungs with growths highlighted by crosshatch images]
[Bright fluoroscopic images of lungs with dark areas scattered near lower segments]
[Images of lungs experiencing symptoms of bilateral spontaneous pneumothorax]